let's speak next to uh how about
alex from fairfax virginia
hi there can you hear me david yes i can
hi david well i'm a relatively new
listener
uh and i really like your content i
agree with a lot
with a lot what you're saying but i'm
also a very uh socially conservative
person okay and this is something that
uh
is something that you talked about but i
was wondering what your take on
abortion is i i know that you're
generally pro-choice and i was wondering
if i could just
um take like 30 seconds to tell you what
i believe about that
and see what get your thoughts on that
is that all right sure yeah
so uh to me i think you know
once someone once an egg is fertilized
in the womb that's when your unique dna
comes out
comes out of where unique and so
uh hold on a second wait a second wait
wait wait
when you said that when an egg is
fertilized your unique dna comes out
what do you mean by that
so the everyone has their own unique dna
and uh and no one's to unless you're
identical twins everyone's dna is unique
and the thing that
and that's the thing that makes you you
you know your your body everything about
you
okay and uh that originates at the time
of conception is what i'm trying to say
sorry if i wasn't clear that was what i
was trying to say that's okay
that originates and so from that point
on
you know the only thing different from
like uh
the fertilized egg to nine month in the
womb
or baby is just time really
and so i feel like at that point from
conception
um that's when a human life really
begins though and that
they should have rights at that point
though uh what do you think about that
let's explore that so by analogy
um it sounds like you're saying that if
i plant
a cucumber seed today and
it germinates meaning at that point it
has germinated is it it has gone beyond
being just a seed it is no longer just a
sperm cell right you and you you know
the analogy i'm using here
uh i i think i'm following okay
the day of germination of my cucumber
seed
the only difference between that and
five months later when i have a full
plant with a dozen cucumbers that i can
eat on it the only difference is time
would you agree with that
i mean so long we don't mess with like
normal processes that happen
i mean we have to make sure the ground
is watered make sure
is i mean i get what their analogy is
going i wouldn't say so i guess
i guess my question is yeah but i might
i would generally agree
i would generally agree with maybe a
little caveat but sure so
would so by your by your uh statement
about the day of the the the
uh you know the first day of conception
and nine months later the only
difference is time
a one day germinated cucumber seed is no
different than a plant with 12 cucumbers
that you could eat and so
would you treat both of those with the
same care and in the exact same way
i wouldn't say that they are exactly the
same but when it comes
in the specific context of like uh
a baby in the womb though uh unlike a
uh a cucumber i do believe when it comes
to human life i think we're talking
about like rights
when you're saying about treating them
the same way i believe that the
there there are rights that need to be
recognized right now
but i'm not saying i'm not saying
treating cucumbers and humans the same
way what i'm saying is
is your understand would you relate
to a one day germinated cucumber seed
the same way you would relate to a
cucumber plant with 12 edible cucumbers
on it
not a cucumber no no so then why would
it be the exact same thing with humans
uh
because generally we relate to humans
differently we do than we do with
cucumbers
okay but i think the point becomes at
what point
do we say that legally
we should be dealing with them in the
same way and the science no science that
i've seen i mean philosophically and
conceptually what you're saying about
the day of conception might
resonate with you but scientifically
i've seen nothing that says that what's
there on the day of conception
is anything like what's there at nine
months never mind
after the second trimester never mind
after the first trimester so i guess the
question would be
you might feel as though these are
equivalent things
but there's no science i've seen that
says that they are
and is there like uh just to make sure
i'm not quite sure what you're saying so
is there
can you give an example of what type of
evidence would you need
to convince you on a science basis that
there would be similar things or
different doctors have different views
some are talking about
at a certain point of neurological
development
others talk about when would when would
the fetus be viable
outside of the womb i mean i think we
have to go to science and medical
science with that question i don't know
that you and i will sort of sort that
out
yeah sure so i understand your so just
to make sure i understand what you're
saying
from your perspective just because the
jury's still out on the scientific point
of view the experts
are still arguing about it you don't
feel the need to
take a stand it's not that the experts
are arguing about it it's that
there's no medical perspective i've read
that says the day of conception you have
something that we would logically assign
rights or personhood to the debate seems
to be
much narrower at a much later period of
the pregnancy
sort of like where most americans
believe
abortion should be legal in most cases
the debate around conception for me
is a false debate it's an arbitrarily
extreme debate
because very few people even think that
that's a debate worth having the debate
really is about late term abortion and
and you know only the most extreme
religious conservatives or social
conservatives are talking about
conception so i don't even engage in the
debate really
because it's just it's not where the
science is and it's not where society is
okay david well uh if that if that's
your perspective i
understand uh i appreciate your content
thank you
for everything oh one last thing i just
want to clear up on
um you said that the science hasn't
gotten to a point
where uh we don't know if we should
assign rights to them
or not i didn't say that what i said is
there is no
case i've seen made that is a
science or or medical case
that justifies personhood and rights for
um cells a day after conception
okay thank you for clearing that up
david i appreciate your perspective i
appreciate what you do and it was a
pleasure talking to you
the pleasure is all mine i thank you
very much uh very very good okay
it's i mean it's a little surprising
people still want a debate
at conception i didn't even think
anybody was debating that anymore
but but people are people are
let's go next to uh why don't we go to
william from minnesota william you're on
the air
hello david can you hear me yes i can hi
i'm just hoping to pick your brain a
little bit
about whenever i'm at a dinner party and
someone says they want to pick my brain
i try to head for the hills that's a big
red flag that things are going to go bad
is that a saying it's a bat yeah that's
a that's a dinner party red flag let's
see if we can recover from it though i
was hoping to hear your perspective
on an untapped reservoir beautiful way
of
uh funds building and reaching out to
new audiences
when it comes to politics um
specifically when it comes to different
streaming platforms such as
twitch and youtube okay it seems like
both political parties just seem to have
this aversion to
branching out into the new generation of
media
um specifically when i talk about this
and thinking about the different
fundraising that can come from
these different platforms such as say
for twitch
uh pastilli an australian um
gamer he primarily streams
escape from tarkov raised 1.2 million
australian dollars
for a children's fundraiser for
children with cancer okay uh let's see
if i can give another another example
uh example dr lupo well i know
what was your what was your question
people people do fundraisers and they
raise money through their platforms give
it given that what was your question
given that why does it seem like with
these numbers
that the political parties and these
different political actors seem to
not respect that as a way to move
forward politically
politically you're saying
political actors don't respect
fundraising as a way or
twitch fundraising as a way to move
forward i wanted to expand on my point
um
but having been cut off it seems like
these
people can reach such massive audiences
and these
fundraisers can gain huge amounts of
cash it seems
like there's just not the will to move
forward to use
uh both twitch and youtube streaming and
the audiences that come along with them
to build a political
political career and i don't understand
why
to build a so you're saying uh someone
who wants to be a candidate
who does fundraising on youtube and
twitch
rather than uh doing the things
candidates might normally do
or even alongside them not necessarily
in spite of what other candidates may
normally do oh
i think i see candidates do that i mean
i've seen you know particularly in the
era of the pandemic zoom fundraisers and
live stream fundraisers i think i do see
it maybe it's
just not being done as much or it's not
as sophisticated yet
i also recall uh congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez
uh doing uh live streaming playing games
and doing major fundraisers for causes
that she cares about so i think it is
being done to some degree
okay um and just as a follow-up question
i was wondering your
um thoughts on the validity of this when
it comes to moving forward in the
political
um climate that we see
i think it's completely valid and i
think it's absolutely fine assuming it
doesn't break any campaign finance law
okay i think that that's
a perfectly nice perspective thank you
very much
all right thanks william there is
william from minnesota we're going to
take a quick break if you're holding
don't hang up because we're going right
back to the phones momentarily